let's bring in jane slater nfl network
reporter
and uh you can see jane on nfl now today
at
1 eastern thursday night football
continues this week with the giants and
eagles on fox nfl network and amazon
prime video
jane thanks for joining us first of all
explain to the audience what you first
reported about the cowboys in mike
mccarthy
well look i i think if you pop in the
tape and you look at the
effort and the confusion and guys
playing
out of alignment particularly on defense
you start scratching your head and
saying
where has been the drop-off because for
the most part we're seeing very similar
personnel from last year now look i want
to cushion that by saying
they had two of their starting corners
on ir they lost gerald mccoy early in
the season
uh demarcus lawrence has seemingly
disappeared from this defensive line
you had your two mike linebackers sean
lee and leighton vanderheist dealing
with injuries so
i'll i'll have those allowances but it
seemed like there was frustration
particularly
from jalen smith early in the season
when he's calling out
this defense and saying perhaps they
could simplify the playbook and
dan i know you've been doing this a lot
longer than i have but when you
typically
see a new coaching staff come in it's a
little shock shocking that early to hear
a player
question the direction or the playbook
of a new staff it just felt
disrespectful to me
so i've been digging in a little bit and
as mike alluded you know we started the
season with
you know they want to handle things
internally and for the most part
players haven't been getting back to
reporters we haven't really been able to
get a sense of are they buying into
things but
if you just look at the tape clearly
they're not i mean everson griffin a
couple of weeks ago even said
he had abandoned his three-point stance
so this is guys it seems like
giving up and mike mccarthy had even
insinuated well it feels like guys are
improvising a little bit they need to
just buy into this defense so he sort of
told you
what i was beginning to find out but i
think what was concerning was
the spirit of it in other words this
coaching staff doesn't know how to teach
they can't adjust on the fly they're
just not good
and when you hear those sort of things
that's concerning that you're six games
and i get the frustration you've got 10
guys on
ir then yesterday mike mccarthy tells us
the backup left tackle to tyron smith
had to go have minor surgery and i'm
told that's going to be about one to two
weeks so that one hopefully won't be
as severe but i you are down to the
bottom of the barrel
as it relates to this offensive line and
again 10 guys ahead of that have been
on ir starters so there have been a lot
of unique challenges for the staff but i
think when you start
losing the buy-in and there's a give-up
you can't overcome that you can lose
guys to injuries
but to lose this got these this many
guys this early in the season
to the process something that we knocked
jason garrett for and jason never got
too high never got too low he never got
reactive and
he certainly didn't this was another
thing that stood out to me the end
it was a lengthy interview with them and
i i appreciate
mike mccarthy answering the questions he
certainly gives his full answer
something that we didn't get necessarily
from the old regime but
when he admitted to me that he
simplified the playbook after the
second week when he was telling us we're
going to be a we're not going to be a
one-call defense we believe in this
personnel
i just found myself going well what is
it are you guys staying the course
are you being reactive this is a team
that's used to a coaching staff that
didn't get too higher
didn't get too low it's just we're going
to play our game but then it sounds like
you are being reactive so
i was a little confused by that
yesterday how many sources
did you have they were anonymous can you
tell me how many
i want to be careful dan because as you
know
and i don't want to specify what sides
of the ball or where this frustration
lies i would say that it's
it's it's permeated throughout the
locker room we'll leave it there
but i know that with a new coaching
regime it could lead to guys not being
here next year
punished we saw it in the past guys like
allen hearns
have gone on the record and and you know
been frustrated about not getting the
ball
as it related to the receiving core and
then the ball didn't come to him so i
want to be very careful i think
i think it's also important to
distinguish there are some egos on this
team
previous coaching staffs have talked
about there would be a standard of
coaching that would be set
by jason garrett some coaches would try
to implement that
and then some of these players would in
some cases go over the head
and it was you know go to the
principal's office and they would
sort of uh back the player and that can
be frustrating
so there are i think there's a couple of
unique challenges that mike mccarthy is
dealing with one
the condensed training camp b you're
bringing in all these new coaches
you don't have the personnel you signed
up for and line item number one you're
starting quarterback
and i think it's hard to develop
relationships with these guys as men
virtually and then when you don't really
have time to sort of cuddle these guys
in your office
that you typically would at a training
camp or be able to take these guys to
dinner when you've just got to focus on
the season so
i also want to position this as saying
maybe mike doesn't have enough of his
guys still in that locker room
and that could change so i think it's
very important to be careful
about what i say here and how we could
connect the dots
jerry jones is loyal loyal to a fault
how loyal
will he be with mike mccarthy i
i think i think the leash is long with
mike i don't think the leash is long
for mike nolan if you talk to a lot of
people in this league who've worked with
mike
the feedback is great guy shouldn't be a
defensive coordinator a couple people
said
they can't understand why the cowboys
didn't see that now if you know
mike mccarthy and mike nolan's history
it makes sense they work together
obviously in san francisco but if you go
back and look at that 2005 team
we're trending very much in the same
direction here so
while you and jerry say i'm okay with
mike
yesterday and you've got mike giving him
the vote of confidence
and saying that this is the defense they
want this is the direction they want to
go
you could see some changes there i've
also heard that
dak prescott has done a really good job
of masking perhaps some of the
deficiencies of kellen moore in his
young career as an offensive coordinator
uh does mike start taking over the
playbook at some point
it certainly gives him an out in other
words after this season you could say
well
you guys wanted kellen moore here we let
him call the plays it didn't work
i'm going to take some more control
after the season so
i think you've got to give mike a chance
at least what he's saying to us
is he's saying he's got an open door
policy i did nfl network yesterday and
james jones of course
played under mike that was james's
feedback that this is a coach that you
can talk to
maybe again because the condensed season
and not getting that opportunity to
really gel with this new staff
players just haven't felt like they
could and given the timetable
and the speed of this season you haven't
been able to fill that out
also you look at the nfc east in and you
can win the nfc east you can go to the
playoffs
and and still have a bad year and still
make it to the playoffs
but you also look at everybody else and
you can play
subpar and get into the post so it's
really hard to assess
how the how the cowboys are hey we made
it to the playoffs
yeah but you were seven and nine or we
didn't make it to the playoffs
and you know the eagles ended up we had
all these injuries like i
i don't know how you're gonna give a
grade to mike mccarthy at the end of
this first year
and i think that'll be a real challenge
for jerry because
this defense i think is going to get
better
i and we can't get worse right but but i
think it gets better i just don't know
if the offense gets better
because zeke elliott i hated that second
contract that he got amari cooper i
don't want him
for 10 million let alone 100 million and
offensive line is a disaster i got andy
dalton as my court
like i don't know how you give out
grades when this is all said and done
i think it's tough given the injuries
and look entries are never been excused
it's the next man up but there's not a
lot of next men
up when we start looking at death you
know i talked about the season
it was sort of an embarrassment of
riches when we looked at they got cd
lamb in the draft and
you know they were able to uh you know
obviously
you know get andy dalton because of
covin and what a backup he was this is a
bona fide starter in the league he's
taking a stand in the playoffs
and then you look at the defensive line
you said look at gerald mccoy and you've
got everson griffin and
alden smith the reports are coming back
strong on him and
now you look at this team and it's just
an embarrassment and i
i think everybody is just fairly
shell-shocked
and i think you're seeing fatigue and
frustration
what i didn't see under the jason
garrett regime
was the lack of buy-in that i'm hearing
and i think that's what is probably the
most concerning
not only to jerry jones and stephen at
this point in the players
but probably to mike and mike even
conceded that yesterday he's had a lot
of sleepless nights because they're not
improving in any areas right now
and so i appreciate him taking ownership
i appreciate him saying you've got to be
careful about calling out professional
football players
i appreciate him saying you've got to
handle this as men
and so to the outside it does seem like
the sky is falling
i think the cowboys just need to get
past this year and i think given some
time to gel
i think mike is the type of guy you want
there i always say this is a unique
position i went to the university of
texas and
you know we're looking at what's going
on with tom herman down there you have
to be not only a coach
but a diplomat and a politician and an
amazing marketer for that position it it
expects so much more than what
he is expecting in green bay in fact i
kind of chuckle when i think about the
conversation i had like in the off
season it had to do with
without giving away too much it had to
do with something that he did not
consider was a big story and it
certainly was
and i said to him if the backup
quarterback
stubs his toe that's a story in dallas
and so i think he's learning that and i
think his staff is learning that
um things are just magnified with the
star in the helmet
is matthew mcconaughey a professor at
your alma mater
he's the minister of culture dan
the moc on campus he's he's the big moc
on campus
exactly what is minister of culture
you know i think he's the you know the
hype man
he makes texas cool uh
he's a professor i'd love to have
continuing education and get in one of
those classes
um you know i used to work for longhorn
network and
got to do a couple of interviews with
him on the sidelines and you know he
would come up here and do stuff
with the rangers and he's a lovely guy i
mean the guy is as charismatic
off camera as he is on camera but texas
has certainly needed him in recent years
to give them something to be excited
about
we interviewed him i think the fiesta
bowl and
uh he was on the sidelines and and like
he's so approachable
but he's so into the game like don't
bother me during the game
and i remember talking to him and you
just feel like you're
a movie's gonna break out when you're
around him it feels like it's
like he's in character right
and then he'll just talk to you a little
bit how's that sports center you like
that
i get like yeah i'd like
is there any who is uh goldie han's uh
daughter's gonna come out here uh what's
her name
uh kate hudson she's gonna come out and
embrace him and we're in a movie scene
here or something but
you do expect him to break character at
some point and he doesn't
uh i was actually in college
in 99 during the bongo incident so of
course he was just a local celebrity
um as a result i mean days and confused
was obviously you know before he was
even the rom-com guy
dazing confused is just so iconic
because there's the moon tower and
there's so many spots in austin that was
filmed in but
just feeling like he kind of felt like
austin he was uniquely one of ours
is how you felt about matthew
mcconaughey and i think a lot of us
appreciate that
he didn't go all hollywood on us and he
returned to his texas roots well also
when i bring up the uh
he played bongos he was naked playing
bongos and i think the police were
called to his house and
he was making too much right like he
thought like
like you know this is my house like
what's the big deal i'm naked playing
bongos here like
you guys got the problem not me i'm not
driving argument to be had there dan
you know you know the more that he
talked to me about it jane i'm like yeah
yeah you're right you're naked playing
bongos and and yeah
you know police never should have come
over there neighbors never should have
complained
uh good luck today with uh the fallout
from this
um certainly stirred things up a little
bit and that burner front burner got
turned up a little bit but uh thanks for
joining us as always
and uh great work there always a
pleasure dan thanks for having me on
that's jane slater nfl network reporter
you can see around
nfl now today at 1 eastern thursday
night football continues this week with
the giants and the eagles on fox nfl
network
amazon prime